from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between domino's pizza in the uk and the
us
this is food wars
this is the smallest pizza you can get
in the uk it's called an individual
and it measures 7 inches across our
smallest is believe it or not
the small here it is and it measures in
diameter
10 inches the next size up is a small
which measures 9.5 inches next size up
for the us
is our medium which is 12 inches
[Music]
this is 11.5 inches
well i'm starving hey
i grabbed the slice i'm starving this
pizza smells so good let's get breakfast
next pizza next up for the us is our
large which is a
14 inch diameter oh hell yeah
what's with the way they cut your large
pizza harry it's ridiculous look at that
and not to be outdone the u.s has one
more size
the extra large diameter 16
inches bro look at the size of this
thing
now a 2.5 inch difference might not
sound like a lot but if you factor that
into the surface area
it's actually 58 square inches wider
than the uk's largest pizza
which is almost a third of an increase
am i looking at this right is it
supposed to be six slices it's six
slices that can't be right
six slices for a extra-large pizza look
at the size of these slices
[Music]
in the u.s at a domino's the extra-large
pizza will cost you a very reasonable
13.99
that is 201 square inches
which breaks down to roughly 7 cents an
inch
nice now shockingly 13.99 will only get
you a small pizza in the uk
a small pizza is 9.5 inches across and
that gives it a surface area
of 71 square inches now if you divide
the 13.69 price tag by the 71
you find out that you're actually paying
19 cents per square inch
ultimately it means that if you went
into a us and uk dominoes with 13.99 to
spend
you'd be able to get more than double
the pizza for your money in the us store
let's compare large cheese pizzas in the
two countries
this is what a uk large cheese looks
like and this
is what a large properly cut domino's
cheese pizza looks like
in the u.s it's cut into 10 pieces and
each slice
contains 176 calories that means that in
total
the pizza in the uk is 1760 calories
instead of 10 we got 8 slices that means
each slice
is roughly 280 calories which makes the
whole pizza
2 240 calories and according to the
thing that was written for me
that is almost 480 calories more than
the uk large but why is that exactly
let's see if we can get any clues from
the ingredients
let's start with the foundation of any
pizza which is the dough
in the uk the dough is made of wheat
flour
a wheat and milk pre-mix rapeseed oil
water
and yeast yes but here in the u.s our
dough is made of
enriched flour we oh god i hate reading
this stuff enriched flour which is wheat
flour iron
thiamine mononitrate niacin riboflavin
and folic acid
water soybean oil and it contains less
than two percent of the following
sugar salt whey maltodextrin
dextrose dough conditioners such as
sodium
sterile lactic
lactolate i don't know it's on the
screen you read it out loud
enzymes calcium sulfate absorbic acid
calcium phosphate l-cysteine good for
hangovers i hear
yeast and cornmeal
uh yeah much different a lot more
chemicals
who saw that coming how about the cheese
domino's in the uk refers to its cheese
simply as mozzarella
and it's mostly because the ingredients
are just that
in the u.s domino's doesn't possibly
can't
call their cheese mozzarella instead
they refer to it as
pizza cheese so the dominoes in the us's
pizza cheese has the following
ingredients
part skimmed mozzarella cheese okay
which is pasteurized milk
cultures salt enzymes modified food
starch
cellulose cellulose non-fat milk
whey protein concentrate natural flavors
and sodium
proponeate prop
ionate propioni now let's look at the
pepperoni
most of the ingredients in us and uk
pepperoni are actually pretty similar
they both contain pork salt dextrose
spices sodium nitrite citric acid
flavorings
and starter culture you know the only
difference is that our pepperoni
contains beef
also preservatives but hydrate hydro
laziness and buddha hotel and blah blah
bha
and bht i can't pronounce them they're
bad
it turns out bha and bht are actually
subject to restrictions in the european
union
and can't be added to foods such as
pepperoni this might be because studies
have shown that bha can cause tumors in
rats
and is therefore reasonably anticipated
to be a carcinogen in humans
oh well
i'm gonna die doing what i love eating
banned chemicals
we reached out to domino's to get some
clarity on the pepperoni situation
we got our info from their ingredients
web page however when we checked with
them they told us that their information
was incorrect
and they've updated it since to say that
bha and bht have now been removed from
the pepperoni
i think this happened at some point
during 2018 they couldn't say exactly
when
but joe it sounds like you're okay after
all
[Music]
here are all the items you can only find
on the menu at the uk dominoes
and here are all the things you can only
get at a us dominoes
let's start with the pizza itself so
firstly
it's the crust options now in the uk we
can actually get stuffed crust but what
we've gone for here is the italian style
crust
apologies to the country of italy for
this one now the italian crust
is basically the same dough but just
thinner and therefore a bit more crispy
there are a few toppings that you can
only get on your pizza in the uk
these include some options we've got
here like meatballs
sweet corn and red onion but that's not
all
you can also get things like catalan
chicken which is a chicken and a kind of
paprika spice
you can get tandoori chicken which is
chicken with some indian spice blends
and you can also get tuna on your pizza
whoa wait did he say tuna
tuna on a pizza no no way
so this right here is a pizza that has
everything you can only get at a us
dominoes first of all
the crust it is our thin brooklyn style
crust
instead of tomato sauce we did an
alfredo white sauce
we got banana peppers on here salami
feta cheese
and also parmesan and cheddar
this should be known as the us only like
pizza hut should have this on the menu
you go give me the u.s
only and this is the pizza they give you
[Music]
yuck don't get this
yeah i hate that grab a slice see what
you think so here are some uk sides that
you won't find on the menu at a us
dominoes
first of all we've got the garlic cheesy
bread chicken kickers
which are just like nuggets with a spicy
coating pretty recently they've added
these
popping chicken bites to the menu which
kind of similar to
kfc's popcorn chicken you can also get
chicken strippers which is just kind of
like
chicken tenders potato wedges if you
wanted some kind of potato option to go
with your pizza
and then you can also get a tub of
coleslaw
i don't think we have garlic cheesy
bread but we do have this which is like
a stuffed
cheese bread also the side they have
these uh chicken pieces
and then these right over here these
parmesan
cheese kind of bread nuts
also i think it's pretty cool this
domino's will hook you up with a side of
grated parmesan
that's pretty nice chicken carbonara
which is a
pasta dish what looks like obviously
chicken
bits of bacon onion in the u.s domino's
offers a lot of different varieties of
sandwiches
i just picked one i got the chicken parm
sandwich let's take a look at that right
there
look at that chicken parm how good does
that look
classic garden salad we found something
green on the menu which is nice
um let's get here tomatoes onions cheese
lettuce croutons
who cares now the default dipping sauce
that will come with your pizzas
is this garlic and herb dip in the uk
but there are also a couple of sources
which are exclusive to the uk
these include a little pop of frank's
red hot sauce
and we can also get a honey mustard
the dominoes in the u.s has their own
exclusive sauces
this kicker hot sauce the sweet
mango habanero sauce this one is really
good
uh ranch you guys don't have ranch
thought you did
guess not blue cheese dressing and
of course marinara sauce and finally if
you're someone with a sweet tooth
domino's has some exclusive dessert
items to the uk firstly we've got
domino's cookies
which are actually like really good
especially if you get them when they're
warm and they kind of stay warm when
they rest on the pizza boxes
and then you can also get a range of ben
jerry's flavors from dominoes in the uk
they're like a licensed fender which is
cool
and for dessert in the us you can get
either these marbled cookie brownies
or these chocolate lava crunch cakes
they also threw in this the sweet icing
i'm sure it's amazing so you can pour
more sugar
all over the sugar let's put some icing
on the
lava guy
oh
that's too much stop all right i gotta i
gotta get this i'm gonna like eat this
whole tray i gotta get out of my face
i'm ready to destroy these brownies
you